fini les cabanes brune le long de nos
grandes routes au québec une chose qui
me rendait pas très fier d'un dernières
années quand on a voyagé partout sur le
territoire québécois
c'est nos fameuses cabanes rue novalto
tiers pas très fier parce que c'est elle
qui ont été bâties dans les années 60 70
on peut reçu beaucoup d'amour
en voici une le long de l'autoroute 20
en mauvais état une halte fermé même en
raison d'un problème d'alimentation en
eau pas d'eau potable et des toilettes
chimiques
à l'extérieur on met plus pas ce que
vous ça vous dérange ou c'est comme le
pakistan c'est quand je dis ça au québec
c'est comme ça les haltes routières
vient jamais d'eau potable ou des fois
c'est pas trop grave mais on pourra voir
mieux que ça c'est désagréable besoin
d'aller détruire d'écouté mais c'est un
fait avec les argent qu'on paie en
impôts est le terreau sas pour être bu
et sinon tu fais ça ce n'est pas un cinq
étoiles nous dit cette touriste ontarien
le gouvernement du québec vient de
décider d'investir 150 millions de
dollars étalé sur cinq ans pour
améliorer les haltes routières le
gouvernement compte notamment y ajouter
des installations sanitaires modernes
avec des salles d'allaitement et des
tables allonger le ministre des
transports veut également améliorer la
sécurité dans ces lieux publics et il
souhaite également interdire certaines
activités disons illicites qui se
déroulent dans plusieurs de ses haltes
routières au québec si on doit avoir des
seins argent ou des agents de sécurité
sur ces halles pour des situations que
vous connaissez le jeu des services
fixes que vous connaissez on le fera les
travaux de modernisation des haltes
routières doivent commencer sous peu
mais un peu tard pour des vacances
estivales
issigeac bissonnet radio-canada à sainte
madeleine